I really want to say a sincere
congratulations I really enjoyed this
movie and if I'm being honest with you
it was a lot better than I expected I
just thought it would be good but it's a
really great sequel
um that means a lot thank you
for both of you um when did you I
actually for uh for someone I'm going to
start with you when did you realize that
the sequel was oh wait this is really
good
um
when we were working together
um
we really spend the time
to explore the characters and the real
issues
and look into the relationship with the
other characters
he was never just saying lines
we really did right it would really did
the work together uh
almost
more than in a regular film because
sometimes in a regular film that people
are not rehearsing anymore everything is
hurry hurry hurry and and he was a
wonderful process of exploring the
characters and the story and the
different meanings that we could bring
what what was what our contribution to
the audience through the characters
today
and uh
I knew it was something special because
also
I love this I I believe in intention
I believe that it's important to always
be aware of your intentions and it felt
I was doing a movie with collaborating
with people that had an intention that
was beyond let's do a hit movie
let's say something and and let's say
something also visually how do we
translate what we're trying to say with
the plot with the narrative with the
characters also visually and and for me
that was mind-blowing so I knew it
quite early on in in in our character
development together and it's
interesting because it was like the same
reaction where you know we set out to go
we can we can really push this next
chapter of Puss in Boots visually like
you're saying everything looks like
you're in a fairy tale painting
um tonally that we go to some new
territory with um especially in a Shrek
world but I think right away working
with Salma and Antonio I was just blown
away by like you were always asking
questions going deeper to like even if
it was comedy it was like what's
underneath this what's this character's
objective here to
um and really how it tied into the theme
of the movie what what does she really
feel underneath the sarcasm the
sassiness every single line and he was
game and he was amazing we played a lot
and really explored and so and I think
you feel that there's a spontaneity
um between all of the characters that
really come so much from from this
process I love comedy I love it
but honestly I hope this doesn't come
the right way to me it's really easy
it's really easy we couldn't improvise
us a thousand times
what else can we do through besides the
comedy or through the comedy I love it
like
I don't know it's you you I guess it
depends what family you grew up grow up
it's like a cheap or something and
you're always making that joke I don't
know I don't know but for me what I
loved was what else is underneath it and
and how does it fit in this new universe
that has to be part of an old Universe
how do you make that all Universe
refreshing
fascinating one of the things about
animated movies is that they can often
change dramatically during the
production and I'm curious how did this
film possibly change from when you first
started to what people are seeing on
screen ah um you know it's interesting
because DreamWorks has been trying to
figure out this next chapter for over a
decade and in the process figuring out
what's
not just making another one just to make
one but
this I think you know what when I came
to the project there was this nugget of
an idea puss is on his last of his his
nine lives and for me it was just such a
great opportunity to go that's an absurd
idea it's like you're a fairy tale that
cats get nine lives but at the root of
it it's about someone who's realizing
they have one life and all of us as
human beings get one life and and for me
it was like exciting to go this can be a
movie that celebrates The Gift of Life
um but how we get there and what the end
looks like I didn't know and that's the
fun of I think of filmmaking of this
process where it's it is such a
collaborative effort there's over 400
people that work on these animated
movies and then we have amazing you know
cast that that really brings so much
not just reading the lines but to the
partnership of creating the story The
themes the character it really evolved
it's such a beautiful end result way
more beautiful than I would have
pictured one of the things I find I know
a lot of people that do voice over stuff
and have recorded voice over and one of
the things they talk about is recording
efforts and how much they dread it and
so some I'm curious for you do you dread
those days where you have to record the
grunting the running those sounds and uh
wow love it
because nothing is generic y'all will
not shut up while you're doing that
because
he is describing of course you're not
looking at it sometimes when you do IDR
you're watching the film and you're like
oh he's like and you're going under this
flower that is going to be purple and
it's very big but it's very scary the
flower so when you go down you have to
like the level of detail and I love like
my brain works only in images
so I could actually be there without
seeing it by the time I saw the film you
know so I'm like no and I love Imagining
the the the the flower and doing it and
he keeps talking to you and now you're
gonna be doing this and that so it was
fun well then and I mean that's why I
found that depending on what I describe
to you it's not nothing's generic no so
the effort changed and so we even every
detail of this down to the effort is so
specific to Kitty softball's character
to that really just you know forms the
the experience the ride I love it it's
playing you know it's it's playing like
when you're a kid I think it's gonna be
my last question uh but Puss in Boots is
a very popular character with a lot of
people and I'm curious for both of you
what do you think it is about the
character that resonates with so many
people of all ages
I mean I think
for me I think there's something in this
it's this adorable little cat you know
is is just a two and a half foot tall
cat
but with Antonio's voice the the
Charisma he's he has like the bravado of
an eight foot tall man and there's
something in that contrast that is both
adorable and aspirational
um I think that that's something that's
very Charming about it to me but I'm
gonna be okay I hope I don't get into
trouble I love when she says this
there's there is an Unapologetic
um and also naive
Charming narcissism
she nailed it that it's irresistible
because it doesn't mean any he all he
wants to do is do good things for others
you know and it's one of his weapons
you know these like
you know the delusional
yeah
and in this movie you see the fragile
part and you love him all the more
because of it yeah you see what's behind
the the bravado because I mean he sings
a song about himself at the beginning
and it's like you say it's Charming the
arrogance is charming yeah it's right
because it's a good he's not a bad
arrogant person but God
he's a nice good God he wants to do good
for the world and one of his weapons is
his
um very robust self-esteem
completely listen I gotta rap I'm just
gonna say uh congrats on the movie and I
sincerely hope it's a huge hit for you
guys uh thank you so much